FBI facilitated censorship requests on
behalf of Ukrainian intelligence agency
compromised by Kremlin wow that's a
mouthful okay so let's slow this down so
the Ukrainian intelligence agency is
going to the FBI and being like we want
these ideas censored and they're like
you got it boss meanwhile it was
actually the Russians facilitating it
how incredible is this a new report
released by the house committee on the
Judiciary and the select subcommittee on
the weaponization of the federal
government has revealed that the FBI
under Joe Biden facilitated censorship
requests to American social media
companies on behalf of a Ukrainian
intelligence agency infiltrated by
Russian aligned actors
okay uh let me turn wrap my hand around
this does that mean the people who are
getting who are doing the censorship are
actually Russian uh uh useful idiots I
have no idea no no so this this story is
Russians pretending to be ukrainians got
the FBI to censor people
so that means the people being censored
were being censored at the request of
Russians Joe Biden
his administration
inadvertently colluded with the Russians
to silence Americans yeah Joe Biden's a
Russian puppet and I think I can say
that well maybe because well here's the
thing people people accuse Donald Trump
of having been a Russian puppet I don't
believe that's true but if he wanted to
choose to be a Russian puppet he could
have been the thing about Joe Biden is
he's in a very precarious position
because it's very easy to become a
puppet when you don't have a brain and
anyone who sends him any information
that is vetted by the people around him
who supposedly care about him who I also
don't think are necessarily the
brightest Minds this country has to
offer can get him to say and do things
that are very much not in line with the
interests of this country
so yeah Joe Biden censoring people on
the behest of a foreign power because
there was misinformation spread by that
foreign power that eventually reached
him is not exactly a shocking thing but
I just want to point out once again
the Democrats were the ones doing what
they were accusing yeah the Republicans
of doing prediction as usual Beyond
projection also uh smash the FBI into a
thousand pieces and Scatter it to the
wins just saying
yeah that sounds about right yeah it
sounds good to me I guess the larger
question is what do we do to solve a
problem like this
what do you think I have no idea we
can't mine you got it it needs to be you
you have to figure this out right now
pressure's on yeah I have no idea but I
mean you're right I mean he's a puppet
anyway you know you could get him to do
just about anything but that's
interesting that they've got it framed
like that the FBI was working on behalf
of the Russians right insane that's
amazing yeah isn't it maybe the real
goal is to deflect the US away from what
China is doing
the Russians want us preoccupied maybe
everything they're doing is a
distraction so that China can move on
Taiwan which is substantially more
important strategically than Ukraine is
to Russia before all those new chip Fabs
can be built in the desert yeah and then
think about this the people who get
centered on social media tend to be
right-wing and tend to oppose the war in
Ukraine
that's a good point why would Russia
want these particular individuals
censored unless they were targeting the
left or liberals or something like that
it'd be interesting I'd be interested to
see what those what the censorship
requests were what what was censored at
the behest of I guess now Russian moles
and Ukrainian intelligence which is a
crazy statement to make but this is
amazing the SB this is Russian
intelligence sent the FBI lists of
thousands of social media accounts
accused of spreading Russian
disinformation which the U.S agency then
distributed to social media platforms
Facebook Instagram YouTube and Twitter
holy crap wow compromised by Russia who
could have seen that coming not on the
bingo card yeah we've honestly developed
a very strange view of Russia over the
past five or six years you guys remember
about 10 years ago
when Mitt Romney said that Russia was
going to become a massive geopolitical
threat and everyone laughed at him and
to be fair rightly so Mitt Romney is to
be laughed at but this was something
that even the left thought was
ridiculous at that time and then as soon
as he became politically advantageous to
them to start blaming Russia for
everything they did and they haven't
stopped they have not stopped and now we
have uh the administration I guess maybe
changing their tune on that of course
inadvertently it seems
I've been saying that ironically for a
while but the more and more that you
talk about it potentially being China
and Russia essentially playing playing
blocker for it that's what I kind of
think is happening it's unfortunate but
that's what I think has happened we
talked about World War III I guess the
question is is all of this a distraction
or what will lead up to say the invasion
of Taiwan which is really going to kick
things off
yeah I I there's part of me that's that
thinks that regardless of what happens
uh what the Chinese do in in relation to
Taiwan the U.S can't really do anything
about it as far I mean this is you know
this is an un uh unexpert opinion
because I'm not I'm not a geopolitical
uh expert or anything but I just don't
see the United States you know having
the the wherewithal to actually go to
you know have any kind of combat in in
the South China Sea over Taiwan if I
understand correctly where you know we
don't have the Munitions the U.S
military power is is is down 25 I think
is the the recruitment goal that they
were down last year that they missed it
by
um overall I don't know exactly which
branch had what the deficit was for each
branch but they're not making
recruitment goals they're sending all of
the bombs and and stuff that we have
over to Ukraine in our stores of of
Munitions of have run low if I
understand correctly so that's that's
also just good for a lot of like the
military industrial compact because they
want to make new ones yeah but what I'm
saying is I don't see how that's true
and I agree with you but I don't see how
how the US is in a position to to
actually engage in any kind of Defense
of Taiwan especially if we're
what amounts to a two-front war at least
logistically like we don't have you know
people on the front lines in Ukraine but
we're you know sending Munitions to the
Ukraine as if we're engaged in it so a
two-front logistical War I don't see the
U.S Being able to handle that well I I
mean I can't speak too much to like the
tactics or what we have with respect to
you know Munitions or anything like that
but what I'm curious about is how the
United States would be able to get
enough people to sign up to fight in any
of these wars
um I I think a lot of the people who are
supporting the Russia Ukraine war are
not people who are going to enlist for
combat roles in the US military I think
that if China were to invade Taiwan
there's probably more people who would
be willing to enlist to fight that war
but I I can't imagine enough people for
that to be a possible reality would be
willing to sign up so the question is
what does the government do I mean how
does the government get people to enlist
if if this happens the moment there
becomes a true existential threat to the
United States all of these leftists are
gonna start scramming good the America
is bad and it shouldn't exist anyway I
think so yeah they're not going to fight
anything they're going to be like yay
yeah or run or or what they'll do is
they'll demand that other people fight
it for them this is this is something
kind of remarkable to when you you look
at how much we've stratified as a nation
how much we've broken apart how little
people see themselves as part of a
common project anymore when you look at
what happened on 9 11 you know New York
City was attacked and a bunch of guys
from the south signed up to fight a war
because of it do you think that
Southerners would would enlist to fight
a war if New York got attacked today I
think few of them probably would I think
we don't see ourselves because at that
time it was understood that was an
attack on on our nation I think today we
don't really see ourselves as a unified
whole and I think if one part of the
country got attacked way fewer people
would feel as if it was an attack on our
entire country and they would just see
it as an isolated attack on that group
of people I don't think we view
ourselves the same way we did in 2001
with respect to National loyalty I don't
think we see ourselves as as loyal and
also I think whether we would sympathize
uh with them enough to like enlist in
some kind of conflict or whether people
in other parts of the country would is
also going to be highly dependent on who
attacks them I I agree with you pre-
attack I think that the temperament of
the most people in the U.S would change
post a dramatic attack I think that that
your assessment is correct like the way
that the the the the the stratification
of the the population of the U.S has
gone in the past 20 years I think you're
you're dead on but I do think that a
massive attack that claims a lot of
lives or is dramatic would change now I
don't think that it would happen the
same you don't think there'd be any
change at all nope I do yeah everybody
thought that Kobe would unite the
country they're like oh man this this
virus no way yeah well I think what I
think what might end up happening is
there would just be like competing
narratives on which political party was
to blame even if it was a foreign nation
that attacked us people on the left
would say this is because the right
wasn't too uh wasn't hawkish enough
people on the right would say this is
because the left wasn't serious enough
about the threat I think it would become
a culture warish I think it would become
a first right if New York had attacked
today the the laugh would come out and
be like the right wasn't taking Russia
seriously and we've been screaming and
they're out like oh screw you you know
what you're talking about you escalate
attention yeah you were the ones who are
causing the fighting in Ukraine we're
trying to tell you to stop we're not
defending you this is your problem you
cleaned it up
yeah true
yeah I don't know I still think I mean
when it comes to Taiwan I think the the
main reason that people that China wants
someone is also it's partly for like
political gain inside inside China to
say like oh we've United China looking
meant to for a long time it could be she
like all the Chinese presidents for
years had like their crowning
achievement it could be what he's doing
to like you know uh leave the leave with
his good Legacy but they need the chip
fabrication that's the valuable part and
that's so easy to to tamper with to
destroy it could be done with by
Taiwanese people inside the country
immediately I don't I don't I know
Taiwan or Ukraine is important for the
warm water port for Russia I I don't
know I just I just I think Taiwan as as
much as I hate to say it you know like
it I don't know if people would be
willing to go and jump for that war just
as much as they would be willing to jump
for Ukraine and be the same kind of
stalemate people aren't going to want to
go do it yeah well I think also when you
look at the country in 2001 people were
all willing to come together and uh
agree that Al Qaeda was an enemy that
they were real existential threat
obviously we all believe that that was
misapplied in retrospect when you look
at the wars we went to but today whether
you're talking about Russia you're
talking about China for the most part
the American people have no agreement on
who their enemy is other than to agree
that our enemy is one another that's
what the American people believe today
that's how we see the country we are
each other's enemy thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time